Now I heard that you were meeting to get in touch with me, but then I heard you were dead
And I also heard that you were a king and various other things
But the fact is Loki you and I are not the sword people understand
Sort people fear
Now I got the information that I needed now. I have to break your neck
It's just the way it is. I'm not I'm just a messenger
I'm dying. You should choose your words more carefully
Now resurrections this time
Hey everybody, this is kind of funny. Danos just being the totally casual bro. I'm just the messenger
I have to break your neck, but this is no big deal. So you could probably see why they deleted this
This is from really early in the stage when they were trying to perfect the Thanos capture performance
So the cool thing about this though, is that it actually lets us know what?
Santos knew about what was going on in the Marvel Cinematic Universe after the Battle of New York
There's a new round of that infinity war blu-ray giveaway going on that I'll talk about at the end of the video if you're new
To the channel. Be sure to subscribe to get everything
It's gonna get really crazy with venom and Captain Marvel really soon the funny thing about this is that now we know that he heard
About what was going on with Loki after Thor the dark world pretending to be Odin?
So the reason why he just showed up now
I think I talked about this in a previous video the Russos actually clarified why?
Thanos waited so long to collect all the stones in the real key to everything
Was him getting the location of the soul stone or at least finding out that Gamora knew where it was from nebula
So that implies that this post-credit scene from age of ultron is happening right after she came back to try and kill him
Remember, it's not totally linear with this post-credits scene
this is happening right before he goes to Xandar and that's happening within the span of a week of infinity war because this is that
The events of infinity war only take place over the course of a couple days almost less than that
That's how quickly things go down how quickly he just jumps around the universe
collecting all the stones the thing about him knowing who Tony Stark was that's actually from after the Battle of New York because people
Reported that Tony Stark blew up his ships with that nuke at the end
So we know all the Loki truthers out
There are talking about theories about how he could come back what's going on here most of those theories rely on
ignoring what the Russos have said about the Hulk
Character as well as ignoring what the meta commentary of this scene here is especially when Thanos says no resurrections this time
so the thing about that the reason why this clip is so important is because they're winking at the camera and it's a reference to
Three different things one
It's a reference to the last time Santos
Resurrected Loki after the first Thor film and taught him how to use the mine stone and set him on the path to conquer earth
And take the space stone back during that first Avengers film - it's a meta joke about all the times
the movies have faked Loki's death
They also did that during thor ragnarok with a play like we thought that he was dead, but nope he'd faked it
He's totally alive in three
It's meant to tell you that Thanos is really killing him here and he will not be brought back to life
Literally no resurrections as in the filmmakers and Kevin Feige are saying we're not going to fake Loki's death this time again
the reason why Loki is showing up in all these
Avengers for behind the scenes pics from the Battle of New York where they're all walking around in their original Avengers
Costumes is is because it's the Loki from that period from before Thor the dark world before Ragnarok before the events of infinity war
It's not our Loki here that's lying in this pile here coming back in the next film
This Loki is dead
But originally when he did say the Sun will shine on us again - Thor I think what he was
Referencing was the sun shining on new Asgard after Thor builds it as Odin kind of told him to do during Ragnarok
Bum look at this place. It's beautiful. Look at that
Remember the space home
This would be a fine place for Asgard just implying the future of those
Asgardian characters because as Gardea is the name of new Asgard when Thor builds it on earth in the comics
So I think he was literally saying the Sun will shine down and things will be better
You know your eventually accomplish your goal of helping our people but also this version of Loki shining down on him with this
Devilish grin from Valhalla thinking of ways to cause mischief like even though I'm dead
I'm still the god of mischief. So it's not like I'm just gonna sit around in the afterlife
So remember that even though Tom Hiddleston might be done being a big character in Marvel movies Thor speaks with Odin in Valhalla
During Ragnarok after he's died so he could do the exact same thing with Loki but no resurrections means no resurrections
So I don't ever expect this Loki to come back to life
But here's the thing, you know multiverse theories time travel still totally fair game for future movies, though
There's still a lot of questions about what happened to cord
Valkyrie in hella because we saw hella seemingly die at the end of Ragnarok
She's such a big character
and Cate Blanchet
is such a big actress that I think that any time that they want to bring her back and she wants to come back she
Will just pop up like oh I was alive this whole time but within the context of the story, she's the goddess of death
So literate like she's probably one of the hardest people to kill in the Marvel Universe
aside from Thanos who just so physically
Resilient even without the Infinity Gauntlet that you need a couple people to take him down
Tessa Thompson, who said that she totally wants to come back Kevin Feige
The producers have said that she basically escaped that as guardianship with Korg in about half of the Asgardian
So there's still half of them that are alive
Everybody didn't die on this ship here. Thor actually had one of the biggest arcs during infinity war
It'll be a lot clearer during Avengers 4 when they're all together, like they'll still be groups during Avengers 4
But they will spend a good part of the film together as Avengers like this original scene here
like obviously all these things calling back to that first Avengers film the funny thing about core 2
I talked about it in my guardians video a little while ago because I was talking about tyka but he actually already
Recorded a new dialogue as Korg so Korg is confirmed alive and daryl is confirmed alive
Good evening, everyone and welcome to the first meeting of the revolution 2.0 or as I like to call it the re revolution
Good news
Darrell survived the snap
Bad news a lot of my co-workers didn't so I'm working
Sundays, let me know in the comments though
Tom Hiddleston cameos in a future film not Avengers for what do you want them to do with the character?
Do you want him to just give Thor advice from Valhalla?
Like if Thor has a problem and whatever next film he pops up in you know
What I'm gonna do just because the spider-man ps4 game is out next week
I'll do the giveaway for the game instead of doing the infinity war blu-ray
We'll do that for the rest of the Marvel videos in the next week or so
Congratulations to the winner from my last big video sock. Please email me on the back end of my channel
I'll do a new round when I post new Marvel
There's an Iron Fist trailer that I'm probably gonna post next so that should be up in a little while
click here for my new sinister six spider-man far from home video and
Click here to learn about what's going on with guardians 3 and Thor for thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay awesome
See you guys tonight